- Hey guys, it's me, Alex.
I'm with my wife and her
boyfriend, Dontarius.
We just found out
we're pregnant.
Dontarius is the father,
and we're here to do
the gender reveal.
So, twist it, honey.
(firecracker popping)
- What? It's purple!
- That means the
baby's non-binary!
(all screaming and laughing)
(gentle music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
is the host of "Prime Time
With Alex Stein," on Blaze TV.
Alex Stein, welcome
to "The Rubin Report."
I don't know why I'm
talking like this.
- Well, no, 'cause
it's Prime Time 99.
You wanna have the
high energy levels,
'cause I gotta go insane
for the Ukraine, Dave,
so this is why we are gonna
go, for your audience,
this is Prime Time 99, I
need you to watch this show.
There's like a million
people watching this,
so I'm begging you, please.
So let's get on
with this interview
before I go insane for
the Ukraine too much.
- Stein, you are
on the short list
of people I consider funny.
I used to have a lot of
people I consider funny,
now there's very few of them.
For people that don't know
you, how did you become funny?
Where you come from,
what's going on here?
- Well, you know, I'm really
not even that talented.
I'm basically, I was dropped
on my head as a child.
I say that jokingly,
but I really was,
I actually had a metal crib,
because I broke so
many wooden ones,
'cause I was kind of
a rambunctious baby.
But I think that my formula
for comedy, it's very simple.
All I try to do is mix
absurdity with reality.
I try to make the most
absurd things seem real,
so that when people
watch it, they're like,
"Is this real or is this fake?"
And then that questions the
reality in which we live in.
And that is a formula for humor,
because you know this, as a
broadcaster, as a comedian,
all, anything that's
funny has truth in it.
So you just mock
the true status quo
that they're trying
to ingratiate,
and trying to make
us all follow.
You just put a mirror
up to that absurdity,
like Dylan Mulvaney,
and people will laugh.
- Is that how you wake
up in the morning?
Like you're just like,
opening up the phone,
looking at Twitter,
going, "Okay,
they're just writing it for me,
and I just gotta get out
there with these dingbats
and make it happen."
- Dude, I say this all the time,
I'm basically a hack comedian.
I don't even have to
write any material.
I mean the left gives
it, and you know,
sometimes we can make
fun of the right,
but you know this, Dave,
is that we have a uniparty,
and you see all this
stuff with, you know,
obviously you're a
political commentator,
but like, you know,
you see the strife
between DeSantis and Trump,
and all this political stuff.
It's all lame, it all sucks.
Really, at the end of the day,
it's very important
to save our republic.
I'm not saying that it's
not important, but listen,
politics is just
Hollywood for ugly people.
So it's just all annoying,
it's all political theater,
and it's really easy to
mock because it's so absurd.
- You know, it's funny,
one of the reasons that I,
people know that every day
I'm applauding DeSantis,
'cause I think he obviously
is worthy of applause.
But partly it's because of
what you're talking about.
I think he's ushering
in an age of sanity,
and it's like the guy
needs some help doing it.
Probably would not
be great for you,
but it might be good
for the country.
- No, and honestly, you
know, for the content kings,
this is how you can tell
the mainstream media,
the people that suck,
that nobody watches.
I mean, literally, I bet your
views are better than CNNs.
But what I'm saying is
they want Trump so bad,
so when you see the mainstream
media's against DeSantis,
all of a sudden I'm like,
"Oh, well that kinda
makes me wonder too."
And listen, I love Trump,
but he had a lot of mistakes,
with Julian Assange, you know,
the people on January 6th,
and I mean, could
he correct those?
Yeah, I would hope so.
I would think that
would be the first thing
you would have to go after,
and right some of the
wrongs that he did.
But at the same time, to say
DeSantis didn't handle Florida?
Well, you're absurd.
It's like, that's
what I don't get,
is that we can't, you know,
we can't see the
forest for the big tree
in front of our face.
We need to take a
30,000 foot view,
and objectively
judge these people,
and not try to create
false narratives
in order to make the person
that we personally
like sound better.
- Now speaking of
false narratives,
you're often out there as the,
it usually is the lefties,
rampaging through the
cities, burning down things,
protesting, they don't know
what they're protesting,
and everything else.
You've been hit with things,
people have spit on you.
You've probably had acid
poured on your head.
I mean, do you ever
really, really feel like
you're gonna be
hurt or something?
We'll put a little B-roll,
so people can see some
of the video right now,
as you talk us through
some of this stuff.
- Well, yes, I mean, I
go into these events,
and these people are on 10
different antidepressants.
They're probably on, you know,
some sort of hormone
therapy replacement.
You know, that doesn't mess
with your psyche
at all, I'm sure.
So yeah, I mean these
are very impulsive people
that are there looking for,
they're there to protest
and I'm the villain.
And I actually
have a background,
I worked at, you
might not know this,
I worked for the TV show
"Cheaters," for a long time.
So I kind have a
background in reality TV.
And I hate to
describe it like this,
because this is a
serious situation,
but this is the
ultimate reality TV,
when you go into
these, you know,
Hollywood producer,
central casting,
they couldn't, when I
went to San Francisco,
and I went to this trans rally,
they couldn't cast these people.
I mean they couldn't,
literally these people
with the blue hair,
it was every cliche under
their rainbow was there.
And so when you go there
and you put a camera,
people wanna see that.
And yes, I am nervous, 'cause
they throw hot coffee on me,
they hit me, but
at the same time,
it's like when a
dog chases a car,
they don't know what to
do when they get there.
So it's like, you
know, at the same time
they don't want the smoke.
I'm six three, I'm 250 pounds.
I mean, I'm a big man, but
yes, is there somebody there
that probably wants
to take me out?
There are people there
that wish for my death.
So yeah, I mean it is a
little nerve-wracking,
but at the same time, that
adrenaline is kind of fun
in a sick way too, Dave.
- Yeah, well I can see
it kind of feeds you
when you're out
there, but for sure,
like when you have people
right in your face,
and throwing stuff at you,
it's not the most thing you.
You'll probably appreciate this,
about five years ago
I did an event in,
somewhere up in Canada,
maybe it was Calgary,
with this guy Maxime Bernier,
he's head of the
Libertarian Party in Canada.
And there were tons
of protestors there,
they're calling us Nazis,
and all of this stuff.
You may remember the video.
There was an elderly
woman in a walker,
trying to get across the street,
and Antifa is calling her Nazi.
It turns out that her husband
actually fought the Nazis.
Anyway, they're smuggling
us in through the back,
so that we didn't have to,
you know, go through the mob,
and someone threw
hot coffee on me.
And I remember thinking, once
I realized it was just coffee,
and I was gonna be okay, 'cause
you always have that moment,
like, "What the hell was that?"
I remember thinking, "Wow,
I just had hot coffee
thrown on me, like pretty
good, pretty good."
- Yeah, but Dave,
you just described
exactly how I described it.
It was this warm liquid.
It wasn't burning
hot by any means.
- Right.
- You know,
they had had it
for a little bit,
but it was like, "Is
it urine, what is it?"
Because, you know,
they'd throw cold water,
that's a little more pleasant.
That, you know, if you played
football or played sports,
everybody splashed cold water.
That's not, that's a
little more wakes you up.
When it's warm liquid,
you're like, "Uh."
And then when you
realize it's coffee,
I guess it's a
little more pleasant
than like just some warm
urine, hopefully not, you know?
- Hopefully not urine,
but they've drank out
of the coffee probably,
so it's already got some
of their spittle, it's-
- And you know it's got the
viral shedding in there,
and you know, I've
probably been vaccinated
just by going there, I've
been vaccinated by proxy,
by just going to these events,
and bumping uglies with them.
- Were you always
a politics guy,
or was it more that
you just wanted
to be out in the
field with people,
and then it kind of
presented itself?
- Dave, forget, politics suck!
I was just telling you this,
I'm a full blown tinfoil
hat, conspiracy theorist.
I don't trust either side.
I believe that
they're literally.
Listen, this, I hate to
be like this, you know,
but I honestly believe
that people in power
are anti-America.
For me, we are not being
run by human beings, Dave.
We are being run by
multinational corporations.
You look at Ukraine, you look
at Raytheon, Halliburton,
these corporations
that benefit from this,
America has been totally
de-industrialized.
We don't create anything.
I don't know what
industry we have,
other than bombs, bullets,
some crappy planes
that they can't ever, you know,
they spend trillions of dollars,
and they can't even fly
the planes, some of these.
You know, secret projects
that never get off the ground.
So my point is, we
have so much bloat,
and so much wasted money,
$100 billion dollars
to go to the Ukraine.
And there's everybody
on the right,
"No, we have to help 'em,
we have to help 'em."
Forget about the Ukraine, let's
go help our southern border.
I mean, I see this every day,
and I'm not trying to
virtue signal or anything,
but Kamala Harris, they
make it such a big deal,
"Oh my god, there's 20
immigrants at our house."
I'm in Dallas, every day I
walk around Bachman Lake,
it's a lake near an airport.
There's tons of immigrants
with a backpack,
you can tell they have
like a fresh Walmart shirt,
and they're wearing a mask,
'cause they don't really
know what the protocol is.
You can tell they're new,
and oftentimes they're
just walking around,
just looking for
something to do.
So it's a serious problem,
and I'm not anti-immigration,
but I'd like to actually not
get kids sex trafficked here,
not get kids overdosing on
fentanyl at record rates.
I mean, so that's why
I just see a uniparty.
We could stop a lot
of these major issues,
I think we could, but
instead we're more interested
in getting everybody vaccinated,
making sure Ukraine
has vaccines,
making sure we have a
new aircraft carrier
so Lindsey Graham can go
and bust the bottle
of champagne on it.
I mean it just pisses me off.
- Not here in Florida,
my friend, but yes,
I get your point, in
the rest of the country,
that's pretty much
what we're doing.
I wanna throw to a video,
because speaking of how they
just hand you people comedy,
you went to the Committee
on Transportation,
where was this?
- Yeah, so this is
in New York City,
and this is my wife's
boyfriend, Dontarius,
who's basically, he's
also kind of my muscle
at a lot of these events,
especially at the
ones in New York.
You know, a lot of people,
they hire professional
private security.
Not me, I want the
least professional.
No, you know, no
insurance, no nothing.
So this is Dontarius
and I complaining
about a lot of the
transportation noises
that are caused in making
homeless residents,
you know, making
their lives difficult.
- Videotape.
- And we're talking
about transportation.
I'm here with my
wife's boyfriend.
It's just ridiculous that you
guys are gonna persecute him,
'cause he's a Black man.
That's why you guys
are doing this.
This is why you're bringing
so much attention to him.
When we walked in here,
it was absolutely unreal
the amount of security
that he went through,
compared to the amount of
security that I went through.
And this is my wife's boyfriend.
I mean, the things that he
does to my wife is incredible.
And we're talking
about transportation.
Let's talk about Pete Buttigieg,
the transportation secretary.
And he's the best
secretary we've ever had,
because he's a homosexual.
And as a matter of fact,
that's why I started
to become bisexual,
to be more like Pete Buttigieg.
And that's why I've started
to have relationship
with men on the side, and
that's why I have Grindr.
So listen, we need to
get federal funding.
Selvena, is that
how I say you name?
Selvena Brooks-Powers?
We got to get some federal
funding from Pete Buttigieg,
because listen, Joe
Biden's over there,
I know his son's smoking
crack in the Ukraine,
but that doesn't matter.
I mean, Pete
Buttigieg, you know,
I know he's like on a gay
cruise with his husband,
and they're, you know,
like breastfeeding
their babies and stuff.
But they can help the
transportation issues
we're having here in New York.
I mean, that's the
federal boss dog.
I'm Prime Time 99,
I'm a pimp on a blimp.
So I wrote this song,
♪ New York City is so dang bad ♪
♪ This apple is rotten ♪
♪ What have we gotten ♪
♪ Nothing but violence ♪
♪ All I hear is silence ♪
♪ From our leaders ♪
♪ My man's titties are out,
and they are bleeders ♪
♪ Because they get
cut with a knife ♪
♪ He sleeps with my wife ♪
♪ This city is damn too
expensive to get an apartment ♪
♪ We need to lower the rent ♪
♪ But instead we're
going to charge ♪
♪ These poor
drivers more money ♪
♪ But all I want to
do is get vaccinated ♪
♪ Stick that vaccine in my arm ♪
♪ I wanna vaccinate
with this love charm ♪
I love you guys, I'm
Prime Time 99, Selvena,
and my wife's boyfriend
has a lot of issues,
and you know, I just
hate these trucks
when they're trying to take
a nap, and I'm playing Xbox,
and they're trying to make love.
These trucks are
making too much noise,
and they're just
polluting too much gas,
and they're just making
it difficult for my wife,
and you know, her
boyfriend, Dontarius
to really enjoy themselves.
- Thank you, time.
- But you, everybody else got
to speak past the time limit,
so I just have a
couple more minutes.
So what I'm saying is, in this
city, we have serious issues,
and my songs aren't
gonna solve it.
And we have Eric Adams
in the nightclub,
you know, doing god knows what.
- [Selvena] Sir, if you're
not gonna stay on topic,
your time is finished.
- It is, though,
I can't talk about Eric Adams?
Is he not on topic?
- [Selvena] We're talking
about truck routes today.
- Oh, that's what I'm saying.
So is Eric Adams not
in charge of the city?
Is he not in charge
of the truck routes?
- Are you finished
with your remarks on trucking?
- No, I'm not finished,
I'm not finished.
I just don't understand why
everybody else get to come here
and pontificate for
five, 10 minutes,
and I try to talk
about something,
and you try to shut me down.
- Thank you, sir.
- Why is it?
Because I'm a homosexual?
Is it 'cause I'm bisexual?
- Thank you, sir.
- Is that why?
I think they don't
like that I'm bisexual.
(Dontarius indistinct)
- All right.
- Anyway, guys,
thank you so much.
I'm IG Bum, please
help the homeless.
There's a serious
situation out there.
I have to deal
with the, you know,
the trucks and all that, as
I'm trying to sleep on a box
on 42nd, and I think
it should be addressed.
Homeless people are people too.
And I'm a veteran of this
country, titties and all.
- Thank you very much.
- Those are veteran titties.
- Alex, people may be wondering,
what do you mean your
wife's boyfriend, Dontarius?
Before we get into the
specifics of the content there,
which was, you know,
there's a lot to talk about.
- Well, yes, obviously
for the people
that are playing at home, I'll,
in professional wrestling
we call it kayfabe.
That's why The Undertaker
stays in character.
But I'll give you guys,
because we're on the
great Dave "Rubin Report,"
this great program, I'm doing
my Trump, I'm saying that,
because we're here,
I'll break the kayfabe.
I'm not married, and Dontarius
is not really my
wife's boyfriend.
But what I'm trying to mock
is there's so many people
in content creators,
guys like Destiny,
and really there's
just a ton of people
that this like cuckold society,
where they just let
their wife or girlfriend
be on OnlyFans.
So really that's kind
of what I'm mocking.
And when people
hear it, they laugh.
But I'm trying to actually
kind of bring attention
to the fact that literally
we have a society
of like these
de-masculinized men,
where they just let their
wife do whatever they want.
And that's happening, this
polyamorous, you know,
it's a little more common
than we like to think.
And then when I
say it like that,
it kind of makes people
wonder, you know,
what's really going on
with people's relationship.
And it's funny, it's
just funny to say
my wife has a boyfriend.
- (laughing) Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's why I say it.
- So it really is a
thing though, right?
Like this is a little
outta my wheelhouse.
This is really a thing
where married men are-
- It's a canon, oh yeah, yes,
but I'm saying,
but the Dontarius,
this is so, I'm so crazy, Dave,
because I've stormed
"Barstool Sports," you know,
I had a beef with, you
know, and Dave Portnoy,
I really, he invited
me on his podcast,
and then dis-invited me,
because he saw that
I was anti-abortion,
because I went to
an abortion rally.
So that's why I took
Dontarius up there,
and sometimes he makes
appearances on my show.
So he's kind of like canon
in the Alex Stein storyline.
And that's the
weird thing about me
is my hero is Andy Kaufman.
That's who I kind of, you
know, wanna aspire to be like.
- Oh I see that, I see that.
- Yes.
And so that's kind of why I have
all these kind of (laughing)
side stories that are going on.
Are they true? Are they fake?
I kinda, like I said earlier,
I like to make some
absurdity with reality,
and then it makes people
question what's really going on.
Like if you read
my Wikipedia, Dave,
it is written by psychopaths,
it's like the most
negative thing ever.
But what's funny
about it, it's like,
is that real, is that fake?
So I like to blend that line.
- Yeah, well that's, I mean
the Andy Kaufman thing now
makes so much sense to me,
because that's basically
what you're doing.
And speaking of kayfabe,
like he really took the kayfabe
of wrestling into reality,
and then he brought
it back to wrestling.
So he was like
layering this thing,
I mean, really brilliantly.
What an underrated comic.
- He created the intergender
wrestling division.
Just think about
that, I mean that's.
But you know, it sounds so
funny, we need that now.
People are like, "Oh,
what's the solution?
These people that are saying
that people like Lia Thomas
deserve to compete against
biological females?"
It's like, no, give
them their own division.
That doesn't make any sense.
He's the 490th
ranked male swimmer,
then he's the top
ranked female swimmer.
Obviously it doesn't take
a scientist to realize
that they have an unfair
advantage biologically.
So yeah, it's just to
think that Andy Kaufman
saw the idea of men and women
are gonna have to
compete in sports,
and then it's gonna be okay.
It's pretty brilliant,
he really could see
what was going on.
- We'll throw a little
B-roll on that too,
because Kaufman, for
people that don't know,
what he did was he
would get up there,
as a male wrestler, and
he would invite a woman
from the crowd,
and then he would basically
kick the crap outta her.
And people, because of kayfabe,
people didn't know if
it was real or fake.
It was (laughing) brilliant.
- No, and they say it was real.
He started on the
David Letterman,
he would call people outta
the audience and say,
"I'll give you like a thousand
bucks, or a hundred bucks,"
I forget what the
reward was if they won.
And then he would just,
at first it started real,
he would actually pin
these girls, you know,
because he's a man, he could
physically stronger than women.
And then it became where
then he had to wrestle
Jerry "The King" Lawler,
in Memphis, Tennessee,
which was at the time the
mecca of, you know, wrestling.
That was like one of the biggest
territories, quote unquote.
So obviously you can
tell I love wrestling.
But, and that's kinda what
I want my show to be like,
Tucker Carlson, but mixed
with professional wrestling
at the same time-
- All right now I'll give you-
- But Andy Kaufman
was brilliant.
Yeah, go ahead.
- I'll give you one
more wrestling thing,
I mean, Jake "The
Snake" was my favorite.
You got anything for
Jake "The Snake" for me?
- Of course, no, Jake
"The Snake's" great.
I mean, dude, that era of
wrestling was the best,
with, you know, him, and
the Ultimate Warrior,
and Hulk Hogan, and no,
Dude, that was the era,
that was the good old days.
Now I don't watch it, I
don't keep up with it,
but Jake "The Snake," he
was one of the best ever.
Dude, "The Snake,"
dude, come on.
And then what did he have?
- Damien, Damien.
- Yeah, and then what did
he have, "The Snake Corner,"
what would he have,
he had his own little-
- It was "The Viper's pit."
- "The Viper's Thing."
Yes, dude, he was epic,
yes, Jake "The Snake," dude.
- I'll tell you something
amazing about "The Viper's Pit,"
and then I promise
we'll move on.
You know that there is his
special un-aired episode
of "The Viper's Pit," because
he had Hogan on as his guest,
at the height of Hulk Hogan.
And they were supposed
to get into a fight,
but the audience was
siding with Jake.
So they never aired it,
because they wanted Hogan to
be the biggest star of the WWF,
but more people like Jake.
How about that?
- No, I'm not one-ing up you,
I'm not gonna one up you,
because you know you're
much cooler than me.
But listen, I've become friends,
and I just made fun of how I
make fun of cuckolding people.
But this is a real,
this is a real podcast.
We're getting into
the nitty gritty.
I've become friends with a guy
named Bubba the Love Sponge,
who is actually the
guy that let Hulk Hogan
have sex with his wife, have
you ever heard about that?
You remember that?
The leak, the Gawker sex
tape that got leaked?
Well this guy,
- Yeah.
- Bubba the Love Sponge was
on the Howard Stern Network,
on Sirius, he was actually
a big broadcaster there,
and he actually was
best friends with Hogan,
and then this thing came
out, Hogan won this lawsuit.
But this guy I talked to,
I go on his show sometimes,
he talks about Hulk Hogan is
the worst guy in the world.
Not that Bubba is, you
know, the most moral guy.
But he just said Hulk Hogan
had his own locker room,
didn't, you know, it's
called the wrestling,
putting people over, when
you let somebody beat you,
and it, you know,
helps, you know,
put them over essentially.
Hogan would never do it, he
would never put anybody over.
And so he was the worst,
Hogan is a not a nice guy.
- Wow, I Spent a couple
hours with Hogan years ago.
- Did you like him? Was he nice?
What was he like?
- I was in an office with
me, him, and Jimmy Hart
for a couple hours.
Yeah, he was totally cool,
couldn't have been nicer.
- Well, of course, of course,
and that's what I'm
saying, you know,
he probably is a nice guy,
I'm just hearing this from a
guy that has heat with him.
But it's just funny because
now that I sit around
and I talk to him,
I go on his show,
all we do is talk
about Hulk Hogan.
That's why I'm bringing this up.
And I always make fun of Bubba
about Hulk Hogan
stuff with his wife,
but it's just this whole, it's
an insane world we live in,
Dave, and you know,
professional wrestling,
that's kind of what politics is.
I know to try to bring
it all back into this.
It's really like,
"Oh, I like this team,
because they did this."
But then the next week
they do something like,
"Oh, I hate 'em."
So it's really just
meant to entertain us,
and kinda distract us
from actually, you know,
going after these people,
or solving the actual
problems, in my opinion.
- The line I have on that
is that we're sort of
in the show must go on
version of democracy,
and I think Trump really
understands that, to a degree.
So he's just keeping
the show going.
Again, that's why I've
been so high on DeSantis,
'cause I sense he's trying
to actually correct it,
in like a fundamental way,
to get away from the stuff
that is good for your career,
but not great for the country.
Where Trump, you
know, Trump did stuff
with the WWE, remember?
- Yeah, he's in
the Hall of Fame.
- So he gets the kayfabe thing.
- He's in the Hall of Fame.
- Is he in the Hall of Fame?
- Yeah, he's in the
WWE Hall of Fame.
But this is how you
know it's all wrestling,
'cause look at AOC, she
really gets nothing done.
And then, you know, I think
it's "Vogue," or "Vanity,"
I forget which magazine,
said that she's the third
most popular politician
behind Biden and Trump.
You know, I mean obviously
I don't believe that,
I'm just saying
she's up there, why?
What does she do, because
she's an old bartender?
I mean, you know, it's all fake.
And there's 432
congressmen and women,
you don't even know half of 'em.
I go and I sit on Capitol Hill,
and I go and I try
to interact with 'em.
I'm walking around
their offices,
I'm like, "Who is this
guy from Montana?"
Or, "Who is this guy," you know?
It's all, it's
like you have to be
like Marjorie Taylor Greene,
you have to be very,
like, confrontational,
to even get noticed,
to get picked out,
the Dan Crenshaws, the
few celebrity politicians.
And then once you realize
that's what it takes
to become that kind
of famous politician,
and I'm very good
friends with Marjorie,
but you wanna keep your
name in the limelight.
You wanna keep on
pushing the envelope.
So I guess we need
more politicians
that are trying to make
a name for themselves,
but at the same time,
it's all kind of kayfabe.
- Now what's the deal with AOC?
You touched her
butt or something?
- No! My gosh, no!
Now I am gonna go to jail.
But listen, in front of
her boyfriend, Riley,
speaking of cuckold,
he didn't do anything,
I saw her and I said, "Oh, AOC,
even though you like
to kill babies,"
this is at the time
of Roe versus Wade,
a lot of that controversy,
"You're still very beautiful."
And I said, "You're my
favorite big booty Latina."
And she freaked out,
and it would not have
been a big deal, Dave,
but she went on her Instagram,
and made literally 17
stories, "Oh this guy,"
she's like reverse
selfie-ing on her phone,
you know, she's like,
"Oh, this is the guy,
you know, this is him."
She's like literally
showing me on her phone.
She put me, and we keep on
going back to wrestling,
this is the wrestling
episode, she put me over.
She's like, "Oh,
the Alex Stein guy,"
she took my video,
and then she tweeted,
it and then it got
like, you know,
20 million views on
her page. (laughing)
So I couldn't have asked
for a better result,
and I was just trolling.
And at the same time, I was
just making a compliment.
She's so pro-sex worker, she's
so pro-abortion, you know,
she's been a bartender.
For me to say, "You're a big
booty Latina," it was a joke.
And she acted like she's
the biggest victim.
And then she went on,
because I did in front
of the Capitol Police,
after voting for like three
or four hours, she came out,
it was late at night,
it was like 11.
And she said that
on January 6th,
that some of the Capitol Police
were responsible for letting
some of the rioters in,
and that she didn't trust
some of the Capitol Police.
Those are her own words.
So she's just a,
you know, it's easy,
these people have
very fragile egos.
So when you kind of call
'em out, like Dan Crenshaw,
they sometimes
melt like a candle.
- Are you worried that the
higher your profile gets,
it'll get harder to
ambush these people,
because they know what's coming?
- Well, I mean, yes,
but I constantly have
to reinvent the wheel.
Like I can't just always go
to, you know, trans route.
I'm done, I mean I'm
gonna still go to these,
but come on, Dave,
you think I wanna go
to another Drag Queen Story Time
for children in
Brooklyn, New York?
I swear I don't, even
Jimmy Kimmel played a clip
of me doing an
interview and they said,
you know, the guy's
like, "Oh sure,
he doesn't like going to these
drag events," and he's right.
I'm like, "Jimmy
Kimmel, they're right.
They're making fun of me.
I don't wanna go to
these events, but,"
so I'm gonna have to
reinvent the wheel.
I'm not gonna have to do that,
I'm gonna have to get
in politician's face.
I'm just gonna have to
keep doing new stuff.
I can't, you know,
it's like Andy Kaufman.
You gotta create a
new angle every day.
- People know that I like
giving the Devil his due.
That's what I try to
do on this program.
When you go to the
Drag Queen Story Hour,
and you see the parents
there with kids,
putting aside the
trolling for a second,
what, have you ever
had a sane conversation
with one of the parents,
even off camera?
And like really,
what do they think
they're actually accomplishing
by taking their kids
to these things?
- Well dude, you just
nailed the real crux
of this whole thing.
It's a lot of times,
and I've seen this,
and I can see it with my own
eyes, it'll be like two women.
And it's not that
they're a lesbian,
it's usually they're like
a heterosexual woman,
that's getting back
at their ex-husband.
You know, I've seen
that multiple times.
And then there's a
guy, Jeff Younger,
who his ex-wife is transitioning
one of his children
to a girl, that you
know, he doesn't want.
And then you look
at Dwayne Wade,
who transitioned his son,
and Gabrielle Union is the
stepmother who encouraged that,
and the biological
mother has actually sued,
and tried to stop it.
So that's a big thing of
getting back at people,
'cause people are so vicious.
And I know that sounds crazy,
but I see it with my own eyes.
And you're just
kinda like, it's,
'cause I don't see a lot of
the two-parent household.
I have seen that, I
have seen two parents
that look like they
were, you know,
the mother and father of a kid,
but most of the time it's
kinda like two women,
or two gay men, or you
know what I'm saying?
It doesn't, it's not
the traditional families
that I've seen go to these
events, and that's the problem.
These kids aren't
choosing to go,
it's parents taking
them there to be edgy,
or to be ultra progressive.
And really, like, I
think the parents,
maybe their heart is in
the right, you know, spot.
Some of these parents I see,
like maybe they're not so
ingratiated in this weird stuff,
but at the same time,
there's no excuse
to take a kid to a
bar, or to a drag show,
or even a library.
I just, I have very little
sympathy for these people,
but a lot of times it's vicious,
I notice is the
motivation, I think.
- Yeah, are you ever afraid
that we're all butterfly
affecting this thing?
Like, you know, it's existed
for a certain degree,
we push back, we make it bigger,
then they do it to outrage
us, we expose them,
they outrage us, we expose them.
- No, Dave, what are
you talking about?
Dude, do you see this?
Now that we've gone ultra left,
now you see the ultra right,
they get mad at you because,
"Oh, there's a gay
conservative that has a voice.
You see that?"
Because now we've
gone ultra right,
so now we've gone ultra left.
So that's kinda
almost the problem
is we're ultra polarized,
and when most people are
somewhere in the middle.
So I think that's
kind of, you know,
one of the biggest
problems, I guess,
that I feel like as a society,
is now we're so
polarized, you're right,
like since I went and I exposed
a Drag Queen Story
Time for kids,
Drag Your Kids to a Pride Event,
now 10,000 more bars are like,
"Let's do a drag event for
kids," so you're right.
That's what I'm saying, so the
more you push it, you know,
the more farther
right people wanna go,
the the farther left people go.
So it's kind of this
weird dichotomy,
where they almost feed
themselves by just,
it's like a magnet that
doesn't stick together.
You know, they just, wants
to try to push 'em together,
we just become more polarized.
- What else have you been
thinking about lately?
Are you doing anything else?
Well, I guess you're
gonna constantly
be reinventing
yourself, but like,
do you like set these things up,
like, "That's what I'm
gonna do next month,
month after that
I'm gonna do that?"
Or is it kinda just
what's going on
in the news at the time?
- Well, to be honest,
I'm kinda frustrated.
I recently went up
to Project Veritas,
to, you know, I had a bit
where I was gonna go there,
and talk to the CEO about
them ousting, you know, James.
And that ended up kind
of getting messed up.
I had some, you know,
Project Veritas insiders,
and then they got kinda leaked.
So I'm just saying, you
know, I have some, you know,
stuff on the horizon
where I wanna go,
and confront some more people.
And honestly, the thing,
please guys, watch my show.
I'm there at The Blaze,
grinding every day.
I know I'm begging, I don't
care, I gotta plug, Dave,
in front of your huge audience.
I go insane for the Ukraine.
It's literally not telling
anybody to ever do LSD,
but it would be like
Tucker Carlson on LSD,
and he is my biological father.
But no, no, honestly, Dave,
like, what's bugging me the
most in society right now,
it's like, you know,
I wanna say politics,
but I feel like
there's going to be,
and I try to be
conspiratorial, or whatever,
but I just think that
if we don't watch out,
the idea that you saw
Tucker Carlson just put out,
you know, they want us
to eat bugs, I really do.
And it may not be in
our lifetime, you know.
You know, you see all this
artificial intelligence,
this and that, but I
do believe that one day
they're gonna say because
of climate change,
they want us all
to live in pods,
and they're gonna say, "Here,
plug into the metaverse,
and in the metaverse,
and here on Earth,
you only live for, you
live for like 70 years.
But in the metaverse,
you live for 1,000 years.
And I don't believe they're
gonna have the technology
in our lifetime.
But I do believe, and I hate
to be black pilled like that,
I think that's the future
they want us to be,
all one sex, where we
basically can't procreate,
so that they can, you
know, basically, you know,
depopulate the world.
And if you don't think
that's happening, you know,
the idea that they tell every
single kid to get an abortion,
yet every single
person that comes up
through the southern border,
comes from cultures
where abortion
is basically, you
know, despised.
These people aren't
having abortions.
So it's just kind of weird,
they're basically
depopulating us,
right in front of our face.
So I just, I think for
us as human beings,
we cannot point to, "Oh it's
this country doing this,
it's the Ukraine doing this,
it's making my life bad."
No, you are responsible
for your happiness.
You are responsible
for creating a life
that makes you happy.
You are responsible
for doing a job
that you respect, you like,
and not being a debt slave,
and not being a slave to,
you know, social media,
even though you and I
are on it like crazy.
Sadly I kinda say
that hypocritical,
'cause I'm addicted
to social media.
But like I said, it
is important for us
to find our own happiness
and be our own, you know,
the man in the mirror,
you know this, Dave.
It's not the government,
the government's gonna
kick us all day long.
The right side or the left,
the right wing, the left
wing are on the same bird.
So you are in charge
of your happiness.
That's one thing I try
to, you know, tell people
when they watch my show, or
when I come on shows like yours.
- Good, you shift
it very quickly.
You were going black pill there,
but then you shifted to the
white pill very quickly, right?
The black pill is we all end up
in "Matrix," "Ready Player One,"
"Minority Report,
"Total Recall."
And then the white pill is
what you just said there.
You don't have to participate,
and you can carve out
something on this mortal coil
that's pretty decent for you.
- And it sounds crazy, but
if you really look into it,
a lot of these people,
like the Klaus Schwabs,
they have all these
think tank groups.
They kinda tell us
what they wanna do.
You know, they tell us
that they wanna scare us,
or the climate change.
But if you just look at
people, like Barack Obama,
who bought a house
in Martha's Vineyard,
or you look at Bill Gates, who
bought a house in, you know,
I believe like southern,
the south of San Diego.
If these people are so worried
about the, you know,
polar ice caps melting,
why are they all
buying beach houses?
So it's just, it's
very hypocritical.
They all fly on
their private jets,
that create emissions
that are insane.
So it's just, if you
really kinda see,
these people aren't even
following their own rules,
then you don't become a victim.
Because listen, Dave,
now to get really sad,
I joke around a lot, but this
is why I'm a man on a mission.
You know, my mother actually
died in October of 2021.
She was short of breath.
I begged her, begged her
not to go to the hospital.
She went to the hospital.
She was in there,
she was kind of,
she was breathing,
we're talking.
We said, "No Remdesivir,"
they gave my mom Remdesivir,
and she died five days later.
Her organs filled up with fluid,
and she died in front
of my, you know,
right in my arms,
right in front of me.
And they literally
murdered my mother.
They did not have any
sympathy whatsoever.
And these are the
same protocols,
these people like Dr. Fauci,
who tests his vaccine
on eight beagles.
So we really do have like a
medical industrial complex,
where I was a huge victim.
So that's why like,
I like to laugh,
because if I don't laugh,
if I don't make fun
of stuff, I will cry.
So I lost a person I
love most in the world,
and so that's kind of why
I'm on this mission, Dave,
to kind of call
out the absurdity,
because I was a victim of it.
And I don't want anybody
to feel sorry for me.
Do not, your sympathy
is not needed for me.
I hate that when people
say, "I'm so sorry."
I'm not telling you this
to feel sorry for me.
I'm telling you this to warn you
that there are bad things that
can happen to good people.
To my mom who got vaccinated,
'cause her doctor said
that was the thing to do,
even though she knew, you
know, it wasn't tested,
but she didn't
wanna lose the care
of her primary physician.
So people got bad information.
And I, and my mother, were
victims of this thing.
So the only way that I
think I can call it out
is not by being
necessarily super serious,
but by mocking it,
because they mocked me,
and they mocked my mom when
they gave her Remdesivir,
knowing that it was
not gonna help her.
- Well then instead of saying
I'm sorry about your mom,
I'll do the one thing
that you want me to do,
which is give you a chance
to promote your show
one more time.
- Yes, okay,
"Prime Time With Alex Stein,"
and don't feel
sorry for me, guys.
My mom is my biggest fan,
she's my biggest fan.
That's the only
thing that sucks too.
Now I work for Glenn Beck!
Now I got a cool studio!
I got all this crap going on.
I'm making a little bit
of change, you know,
I'm acting strange, getting
paid a little bit of change,
and I don't even get
to share it with her!
So I wanna share it
with you, the audience,
come watch my show.
You're gonna see me go unhinged.
You're gonna see me
happy, sad, every emotion,
because I'm Prime Time 99.
I wear my emotions on my sleeve.
And I just wanna say
thank you so much
for letting me come on
your program, and dude,
it is an honor and privilege.
I know you get hate,
but I think any hate,
not that you get a lot of hate,
but I think that's
what it takes,
like if everybody
universally loved you and I,
then we wouldn't be
controversial or edgy.
So that's what I I think
that makes you so special.
So Dave, thank you so much
for letting me come on.
- Stein, I know you're hunkered
down there with Glenn Beck,
you know, sharing
a bed in Dallas,
but you come out to the free
state of Miami, dinner on me.
- Yes sir, yes sir.
All right, Dave, well anytime.
So this is "The Vice" reporter.
You can tell, the only
one in a mask here.
So how are you doing?
- [Tess] Just doing my job.
- She's here trolling
everybody here.
So she's the only
one here in a mask,
and she's just saying
negative stuff.
I can't believe they
let you in here.
Do you feel like you're a lion,
or a sheep in the lion's den?
- [Tess] I have
credentials to be here.
- Yes, so do I.
But I'm saying, see,
this is "Vice," guys.
This person, she's trying
to troll this event.
She thinks all of
you guys are losers.
So that's what she
posts on the internet.
She posts the most-
(people laughing)
She posts the most
out of context stuff.
See, "Vice" is the worst
media company there is.
They're all liars.
So what do you think about
your crappy media company?
- Just doing my job-
- I know.
- [Tess] And if you have a
problem with me being here,
you can take it up with CPAC.
- I know, but don't you think
"Vice" is a bunch of liars?
- No, I'm very proud of them.
- Oh, you're proud of that?
You know, you guys
maybe talk about drugs.
Are you a drug addict too,
like all "The Vice"
content you make?
- [CPAC Attendee] Talk with
her too much, you know-
- Guys, this is "The Vice."
Guys, this person, she's
a loser right here.
She's the only one in
a mask, you see this?
This is what a loser looks like.
She's got her coronavirus.
How many vaccines do you have?
Are you on your fifth vaccine?
- It's not your business.
- Oh my, oh, it's not?
So why do you wanna mandate 'em,
if it's none of my business?
Are you pro-vaccine mandates?
- None of your business.
- Oh, it's none of my business,
but she's pro-vaccine mandates.
Guys, you see this?
This is what a "Vice"
journalist looks like.
She comes here, this is what a
"Vice" journalist looks like,
in her little mask, at
the conservative event.
Now she's scared, she's
getting attention.
- If you're looking
for more enlightening,
and maybe even
humorous conversations,
check out our comedy playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe, and
click the notification bell.